the government's delayed immigration
bill is due to be published soon but we
know the plan remains to get net
immigration down to the tens of
thousands latest figure short
immigration at nearly a quarter of a
million saw quite a task
for the new Immigration Minister
Caroline Noakes he joins me in the
studio looks very good morning to you
congratulations or thank you good
morning you've certainly hit the ground
running a new Memorandum of
Understanding signed with the the Indian
government to help return criminals
returned illegal migrants explain a
little bit of the thinking well that's
been an MoU that has was started by my
predecessor and we've had the Indian
Minister Kiren Rijiju over this week
talking to him and indicating the
support of both governments for the MOU
that's going to be signed formally by
the Prime Minister and Prime Minister
Modi in April when he is over here but
really important that we have in place
the mechanisms so we can speed up the
returns of people who shouldn't be here
and share information with one of our
allies about criminal records
fingerprints identity so that we can
make it a much smoother process clearly
the most pressing issue for any
immigration Minister is net migration
2010 2015 2017 we had a conservative
manifesto promise to bring it down to
the tens of thousands are you finally
the conservative to fulfill that promise
I think we've done a good job so far
my predecessor is immigration Minister
the current Home Secretary and of course
her predecessor as Home Secretary have
set the direction of travel we're seeing
the trajectory headed in the right
direction but what's really important is
that we make sure that this is a country
that is open and welcoming to those who
want to come here to study and to work
so that we can have the right people
come to this country helping our
communities and economy and make sure
that we stick in terms of the tens of
thousands target your country mile away
from it's still a quarter of a million
net migration this year we're very clear
that's a manifesto commitment and we are
massive commitment which proves that
we're committed to do it and we are
working really it also shows that you're
not very good at living up to your
promises and I think that's an unfair
comment to the new immigration minister
you know I'm determined in my new job to
make sure that we continue that
direction of travel that we were really
to make sure that we have sustainable
levels of migration into this country so
how are you going to do it well we're
going to have a new immigration bill
come forward I know that brexit provides
a challenge and it's really important
that in a post brexit era we make sure
that we have the right policies in place
to ensure that we can get towards that
target I've never said that it's going
to be quick we have to make sure that
the direction of travel continues and
that we do this sustainably over a long
period don't just get just give me one
way in which you'll be able to make a
significant hit to the net migration
numbers well as I've already said we're
working hard to make sure that we
continue with removals with our allies
and the countries that we work place
that's ten is that hundreds that's not
thousands well it has been thousands and
it will continue to be thousands of
people that shouldn't be here and we
don't wish to be here but in addition to
that we have to make sure that we have
the right policies in place and I don't
pretend that's going to be easy but we
have to ensure that we continue to
attract people to our country who have
supported our economy but make sure the
post brexit we have the right strategy
which after all is what people told us
they wanted I mean we referendum one way
to help the figures would be to move us
as a number of your colleagues have
suggested and asked to have foreign
students from the total I mean given the
rate of returning given the financial
benefits that they bring to the UK I
mean that's a no-brainer isn't it well I
think you have to look very closely at
the ons who do the official statistics
and they're very clear that anybody who
is here for 12 months or more should be
included in the statistics because after
all they'll be using services like the
health service in this country so it's
important that we account for the people
who are here correctly and accurately
but we've asked them the migration
advisory committee to look at this issue
they're reporting in September and I'm
not going to prejudge what they're going
to say still I mean there's a skies
bethe reg discovers I mean the Prime
Minister might not have much of a say in
the matter I mean given the government's
precarious majority Scottish Tory MPs we
knew are agitating for this particular
change are you ruling at home what I've
said to you really clearly we have the
migration Advisory Committee they're
independent experts economists who are
going to look at this for us and I'll be
working with them over the coming months
and I'm really looking forward to what
they have to say in September yeah but
what's your view well my view is and
I've told you the the position that the
ons insists on those who are here for
more than twelve months being included
so it's
right that we stick by that we can't be
seen to fudge statistics and that's the
last thing I want to do what I want to
do is to work with the MOC to get the
right solutions
speaking of Scottish Conservatives just
want to show you a little tweet that
came to my attention today it's just
gonna be over your shoulder I think and
it's risk davidson she's out and about
campaigning but flanked by justine
greening well it will appear there at
some point it's late
you know the gremlins have got and in
fact we're showing it we're sure on
another on another school in the moment
just in greening why on earth was she
removed from the cabinet look I really
like Justine she did a great job both as
education secretary and as women in
equality secretary a role that Amber has
taken up in the home office now
Justine worked really hard I was really
pleased to see her on Thursday at women
inequalities questions being supportive
working hard you know it's right that we
go forward with our education policy and
my colleague Damian Hinds who I work
with in the DWP and who is a near
neighbor of mine in Hampshire is
absolutely the right person to take
forward all right I mean I'm certainly
not going to prejudge his abilities and
his time at the department education but
if she was doing a good job just in
greening why on earth was she moved I
wasn't privy to the Prime Minister's
conversations that may surprise you in
Downing Street on lunch your best guess
then but I know that the Prime Minister
was determined to put the right people
in the right place which rather implies
that just leaving was not the right
person for education which which bothers
a number of people well we have seen
some significant changes across
government and a redefinition of roles
and Department so we've seen some
changes it to the Department of Health
and Social Care now I think that's a
really positive and important change and
indeed housing and communities and local
government I think really stressing the
prime minister's commitments on health
and social care and indeed on housing
making them for most in the cabinet
but I don't I don't decide the
reshuffles the Prime Minister does that
and I think the reshuffle that we saw
this week was really positive about
promoting women about promoting people
from BM AME in that government into
government not into the cabinet
we've got more women attending cabinet
than previously we've got more ministers
from Abbey AME background and that's
really important we are a modern
Conservative Party that looks like the
country that it represents
the suggestion from commentators Ian Ian
Martin one of them and he described the
reshuffle yesterday as rubbish I mean
the contention that some people are
making is people like for example Rory
Stuart's Dominic Raab the next
generation who really had an expectation
of being promoted to Secretary of State
right that they weren't they would
ignored so they didn't have any cabinet
experience this year you deliberately
handicapping them just in case they
wanted to run for the leadership this
year or next well I think that's
absolute nonsense and there have been
some great people promoted to cabinet my
colleague Clare Perry
for example Damien Heinz who I've
already mentioned but you know we've
seen a raft of changes at minister of
state level and that's not a junior
level at all people like Caroline Dynegy
promoted and I think what we've seen
some great change is some refocusing of
priorities on the environment on social
care and these are really really
important things for us to be taking
forward if you squint and looked at a
picture of the cabinet it would look
almost the same as it did before well I
would disagree with that and let's face
it I was one of the new faces around
that table me and Clare Perry and that
Hancock all changes Damien at the other
was sitting at the other end of the
table but you know it's about making a
government that is forward-looking a
government that is determined to get on
and do the job effectively supporting
the Prime Minister and we're all really
pleased to be doing that even with what
can clearly be seen as a safety-first
reshuffle the Conservatives were once
again home to mr. and mrs. [ __ ] up
weren't you I mean the the tweet that
was sent out by central office
announcing Chris Grayling as chairman
rather than as we know no Brandon Lewis
I mean Brandon Lewis the new chairman
does have a point your digital strategy
you really need to stop its game and
Brandon's overseeing that and absolutely
the right person to be doing that you
know I think that as somebody who does
tweet that I need to maybe raise my game
on that sometimes I'm criticised for
having one of the most boring Twitter
feeds on the planet don't believe it
don't believe shocking isn't it but you
know some of us use it for for varying
purposes I always focus on my Twitter
feed about the job I do in roms Ian
Southampton north supporting my
constituents attending important
meetings and events there you know
there's a whole range of techniques that
we can use but yeah sure I want to see
more of my colleagues tweeting and I
want to see more of our activists to
attend I just want to move on to a
couple of stories that have emerged in
the past 24 hours and our city editor
mark Kleiman has revealed the fact that
Karelian Luke
you're on its last legs can be
absolutely clear the government is not
about to bailout Karelian in the way in
which it did with the banks so the
government's been working really closely
with Karelian and met karelians lenders
and is determined to work as closely as
we can to make sure that not only are
there contingencies in place but that we
are absolutely prepared and know what
the proper situation in picture is it
would be very wrong of me at this time
to make any comment further on Karelian
but I think it is fair to say that the
government has been working across
different departments those that are
most affected with contracts with
Karelian to make sure that we have the
right strategies in place should the
worst happen but this is a company that
is still a going concern and it's
important that we don't prejudice that I
mean mark Kleiman suggests that the
government is not minded to be alert in
the same way that we did with the banks
what he does suggest is that the
government is being asked to ensure that
certain payments are made at certain
points in the contract again that sounds
very much like the contracts being torn
up and once again the taxpayer being
asked to foot the bill I'm not going to
comment on specifics of the many
contracts that government has with
Karelian but it's really important to
know and to reassure viewers that the
government has worked closely with
Karelian and its lenders to put in place
the necessary contingency strategies
should the worst happen but as I've said
this company is a going concern at
Donald Trump and the visit that never
was and would you have welcomed him with
open arms I think it's really important
for our relationship with the United
States that the president be afforded an
invitation for a state visit we work
really closely with the United States
they're our closest ally we share
information with them we trade with them
so of course the President of the United
States should come here and we should
give him a good well it's a failure on
the part of the Foreign Office to make
it happen Oh
president Trump has clearly made his own
decision about whether he wishes to come
for the opening event suggesting that he
doesn't know his own mind but the
Foreign Office have failed
haven't they no I don't think they have
failed there was never a date set for
the visit and I think it's important to
reflect on that and I'm sure that he
will come here and we will Accord to the
president of one of our closest allies
absolutely the Welcome that he deserves
mm and when will that happen I mean the
problem is this it does rather seem that
the primary the president
the United States has been put off
attending meetings hidden London being a
state visit or otherwise because of the
Mayor of London well the message that
he's getting from the government of the
United Kingdom is that we want him to
come here we want to continue our
relationship with the United States that
is so important to us and indeed as we
move towards brexit we need to be having
welcoming relationships with many many
countries across the globe and we want
people to come here and know that
Britain is open for business
and why we have you I mean the new
Justice Secretary has asked the
government lawyers look again at the
parole board decision regarding john war
boys to investigate the possibility of a
judicial review why well i think it's
absolutely the right thing to do for the
victims of this individual and we know
from the media coverage that we've seen
how hurt and angry they are so I'm
really pleased that David Gork has asked
his officials to look at the possibility
of a judicial review further than that
to look up what happened here with the
parole board and whether there is
anything that needs to be reviewed or
changed and but I think we have to first
and foremost think of those victims and
it's horrendous
for them that he should be out in less
than a decade and I absolutely
understand their feelings on this so I'm
wholly supportive of the proposals that
David corks making Caroline upset many
thanks for joining us and I don't if
it's too late the Happy New Year anyway
thank you very much good to be here